>> WE LEARNED YESTERDAY THE
NATION’S LARGEST ABORTION
PROVIDER PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ABUSED THIS EMERGENCY PROCESS
AND GRABBED TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY FOR
WHICH THEY WERE COMPLETELY
COMPLETELY INELIGIBLE.
>> 27 GOP SENATORS URGING
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR TO
INVESTIGATE PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> A FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE REVEALS
THE ABORTION PROVIDER WAS GIVEN
$80 MILLION IN PPP LOANS.
>> HERE IS HARMEET DHILLON.
>> HAPPY TO BE HERE, THANK YOU.
>> FEWER THAN 500 EMPLOYEES ARE
ELIGIBLE, PLANNED PARENTHOOD
SAYS THEIR AFFILIATES QUALIFY
FOR THE LOAN.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> IT IS COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE THE THESE
AFFILIATES WHICH ARE CLINICS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
THAT PERFORM LARGELY ABORTIONS
VIOLATED THE LAW.
THE LAW BUT PUT THIS PROGRAM IN
PLACE REQUIRES COMPANIES THAT
APPLY FORD HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
THEY HAVE A NEED, THEY ARE
AFFECTED NEGATIVELY BY COVID-19.
THROUGHOUT THE MAJORITY OF THE
UNITED STATES MOST OF THESE
CLINICS WERE ABLE TO KEEP DOING
ABORTIONS, THEY WERE NOT
AFFECTED, THEY ONE OF THE FEW
THAT WERE NOT AFFECTED SO THEY
LIED TO BANKS AND LIED UNDER THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM AND THEY SHOULD
GIVE THE MONEY BACK.
>> A LETTER FROM 27 DIFFERENT
GOP SENATORS, WE URGE YOU TO
INVESTIGATE THE ACTIVITIES OF
DOZENS OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES, THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM IS DESIGNED
TO HELP STRUGGLING SMALL
BUSINESSES NOT TO GIVE
GOVERNMENT FUNDS TO POLITICIZE
PARTISAN ABORTION PROVIDERS,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD SAYS THIS IS
PURELY POLITICAL AND THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THEIR
PERSPECTIVE?
>> MANY OF THE BIG COMPANIES
TAKING THE POLITICS OUT AND
TAKING THE ABORTION OUT OF A LOT
OF BIG COMPANIES GOT THEIR HAND
CAUGHT IN THE COOKIE JAR, TOOK
THE MONEY BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
IT WAS FREE AND BIG BANKS GIVE
IT AWAY TO THEM BUT THIS IS A
0-SUM GAME.
EVERY ONE OF THE $80 MILLION
PLANNED PARENTHOOD TOOK WHICH
THEY WERE NOT ENTITLED TO MEANS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES THAT NEEDED THAT
MONEY, THAT WAS THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH IT WAS GRANTED BY THE
GOVERNMENT DIDN’T GET IT.
THERE’S ONLY A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY SO THAT IS WHAT IS AT
STAKE, PLANNED PARENTHOOD TOOK
MONEY FROM PEOPLE WHO REALLY
NEEDED AND THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED AND SHOULD GIVE IT BACK.
>> YOU ARE SEEING 37 OTHER
AFFILIATES RECEIVED $80 MILLION
IN LOANS, LET’S GO TO THIS
DIRECT QUOTE FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, QUOTE, IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD’S HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATION ELIGIBILITY FOR
COVID-19 RELIEF EFFORTS AND
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION USING A POLITICAL
AGENDA AND DISTRACT FROM THEIR
OWN FAILURES IN PROTECTING THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC FROM THE SPREAD
OF COVID-19 BUT THIS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THEY SAID IN
MARCH AS WE GO TO THIS QUOTE
FROM MARCH 2, ’05, THE BILL
GIVES THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION BROAD DISCRETION
TO EXCLUDE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES AND OTHER NONPROFITS
SERVING PEOPLE WITH LOW INCOMES
AND DENY THEM BENEFITS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK CHANGED
BETWEEN MARCH 20 FIFTH AND NOW?
>> LET ME TELL YOU HOW THIS
PROGRAM OPERATED.
I’M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I
WENT THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
IF YOU HAD A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH A BANK THEY LOOK THE OTHER
WAY, EASY TO PROCESS A
CONTRIBUTION TO AN EXISTING
LENDER OR CUSTOMER A SMALL MOM
AND POP STANDING ON ITS OWN 2
FEET AND NEVER NEEDED A LOAN.
THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THIS
PROGRAM AND SHAME ON THE BANKS,
THE BANKS HAVE A GATEKEEPER
ROLE, THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE SIGNED OFF IF THEY
NEEDED IN AND APPROVED IT, THEY
HAVEN’T DONE THAT AND IT IS NOT
JUST PLANNED PARENTHOOD, THERE
ARE BIG COMPANIES THAT DID IT
THAT CALLED OUT BY TREASURY AND
THEY GAVE THE MONEY BACK AND
THEY SHOULD DO THE SAME.
>> THEY HAD TO REALLY FIX A LOT
OF PROBLEMS THE WAY THEY HANDLED
SMALL BUSINESSES.
LET’S MOVE ON AND TALK ABOUT
VACCINATION.
EVERYONE’S GETTING EXCITED AT
THE POSSIBILITY THIS FALL WE
COULD HAVE A LOT OF VACCINES
AVAILABLE.
THE IDEA THAT MAYBE WE MIGHT
HAVE TO TAKE THIS VACCINE, WE
MIGHT BE MANDATED TO.
HERE IS ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
>> THE VACCINE IS EXTREMELY
SAFE, TO TELL YOU, IF YOU DON’T
WANT TO TAKE THE VACCINE YOU
HAVE AN OPTION.
WHAT YOU DON’T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
RECIRCULATE IN SOCIETY WITHOUT
BEING VACCINATED.
ROB: WHAT USING OF THIS?
THE IDEA THEY MIGHT FORCE YOU TO
TAKE THIS NEEDLE?
>> THERE IS ANOTHER PART OF
THIS.
IF YOU DON’T WANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE ABLE GRAB YOUR ARM AND
JABBED A NEEDLE INTO YOU.
THAT IS NOT UNITED STATES LAW.
IS CORRECT THEY CAN RESTRICT YOU
FROM CERTAIN ACTIVITIES,
SCHOOLS, IF CHILDREN ARE NOT
VACCINATED, THEY CAN’T GO TO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT WE DO HAVE
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY AND AUTONOMY
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION BUT
SOCIETY HAS ITS INTEREST AS
WELL.
IT IS DICEY TO EXPECT A LOT OF
AMERICANS TO TAKE A VACCINE THAT
IS BARELY TESTED AND HASTILY
ROLLED OUT.
I’M NOT EAGER TO TAKE IT UNTIL A
FEW MILLION PEOPLE TAKEN AND
DON’T DROP DEAD.
IT IS RATIONAL TO TAKE VACCINES
AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN TESTED.
IT IS GREAT FOR SOME PEOPLE,
YOUNG PEOPLE, HEALTHY PEOPLE BUT
IF YOU HAVE RESPIRATORY ISSUES
OR OLDER YOU MIGHT WAIT AND SEE
HOW IT GOES.
ROB: THE FIRST PERSON IN THE